Now how do we actually compute
these types of things for images.
How can we actually deblur imagines
that are actually because of focus.
So here are two different
sets of examples.
These are actually approaches
proposed by Levin et al., in 2007.
Basically, the two methods
they proposed as one exploit,
prior information on natural images.
Look and model the types of signal
deconvolutions that happen from natural
images like this.
And actually use that to figure out
depth discontinuities and discrimination
that will allow us to improve
deconvolution and also depth estimation.
So, you know, natural images or scenes
like this, unnatural images would be,
you know, random noise types of things.
The other method, and this is the one we
will actually focus on in this lecture,
is basically come up with
different patterns and
that basically use these
patterns on the lens itself.
So make a defocus pattern that is known.
In this case, it's the aperture itself.
But change the defocus pattern to have
some sort of a characteristic like this
and use that discriminate where
the defocus is differently for
different planes of defocus
planes in an image.
Again, we'll talk about
this in lot more detail.
And the idea really comes up is that
what we want to do is come up with
a coded aperture.
An aperture that would have different
characteristics like this, and
you can put this inside a lens
before the image is formed,
the amount of light that goes in
through the lens, through the sensor.
If you can put this in,
we can actually perhaps,
quantify the defocus on the sensor.
And that will actually let us know how
to deconvolve it based on the fact
that we have actually quantified
what the focus plane would be.